merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france
alors selon vous est-ce qu'il faut
reporter la rentrée scolaire si oui
pourquoi pas écouté non à l'est cpe nous
ce qu'on veut c'est que tous les enfants
puissent reprendre le chemin de l'école
en fait ce qui est déplorable c'est que
à moins de quinze jours de la rentrée
scolaire en fait on se pose cette
question aujourd'hui et c'était vrai que
à moins de quinze jours de la rentrée
scolaire
nous n'avons toujours pas d'information
sur l'évolution du protocole sanitaire
donc ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même pas sérieux et surtout ce n'est pas
normal
une fois de plus nous mettons les
familles et les enfants dans une
situation de l'angoissant de questions
sans réponse et en fait on recommence
comme on a pu vivre ce qu'on a déjà vécu
à partir de mai lorsque le chemin de
l'école était possible
c'est pas sérieux puisque depuis mai
dernier aussi bien fc peu comme
l'ensemble des acteurs de la communauté
éducative ont demandé au ministre de
l'éducation de préparer cette rentrée
scolaire et aujourd'hui on voit bien on
fait le constat malheureusement que rien
n'est prêt et qu'en tout cas il n'y a
pas vu ce travail faire réaliser avec le
ministre de l'éducation et le
gouvernement donc se placer juste pas
sérieux et ce n'est pas normal que les
choses se passent comme ça encore une
fois voilà il n'y a pas de respect aussi
bien vis-à-vis des parents qui siège
dans tous les conseils d'administration
et donc ils sont acteurs en fait et qui
font des choix avec avec les équipes
enseignantes sur par exemple
l'organisation d'une rentrée scolaire
aujourd'hui voilà on en est là et c'est
bien malheureux en fait l'écart la du
monde on se souvient de ces mesures
prises à l'école à la demande du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
distanciation social gel hydroalcoolique
port du masque pour les enseignants est
ce que ces mesures sont suffisantes
aujourd'hui selon vous bah écoutez en
fait aujourd'hui il faut aller il faut
aller plus loin et justement ça fait
partie des propositions que la fcpe a
fait au ministre de l'éducation sauf
qu'on n'a jamais
retour c'est à dire qu'en fait il faut
organiser aussi la classe autrement en
petit effectif donc par groupe pour
permettre justement parce que le virus
se propage - ensuite bien sûr il fallait
enclencher des travaux assez conséquent
sur l'ensemble des sanitaires au niveau
des écoles des établissements au niveau
national puisque en fait on sait très
bien que l'état des sanitaires
aujourd'hui est déplorable dans beaucoup
d'écoles bon dans beaucoup
d'établissements scolaires
donc ça ça n'a pas été fait non plus
donc aujourd'hui pour respecter les
gestes barrière il faudrait que les les
élèves dans les enfants puissent aller
dans les sanitaires quand ils le
souhaitent et quand ils en ont besoin
par exemple lorsqu'un lorsqu'un enfant
tous il faudrait qu'ils aillent se laver
les mains et en fait ce n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui parce que les
points de on ne sont pas assez nombreux
voilà il ya toute une organisation à
prévoir et il aurait fallu commencer à
la prévoir dès mai dernier en fait et
pas attendre - à moins de quinze jours
de la rentrée scolaire pardon se poser
la question comment on va faire pour
organiser la rentrée
bon ok donc dans quel état d'esprit sont
sont les parents que vous côtoyez va
écouter les parents en fait encore une
fois et on en fait ils sont très déçus
parce que on a l'impression comme je le
disais tout à l'heure d'en revivre la
même situation qu'en mai aujourd'hui on
sait très bien que les enfants veulent
tous retournés à l'école que c'est
nécessaire en fait pour bien apprendre
il faut il faut apprendre à l'école avec
ses camarades avec ses enseignants et en
fait aujourd'hui les parents sont plutôt
inquiets en plus il ya des parents qui
ont des enfants avec une santé plus
fragile
ben en fait ils se disent que c'est pas
possible là aujourd'hui au vu de ce qui
se prépare les conditions sont pas
requises pour que tous les enfants
soient en sécurité surtout ceux qui on
voit là une santé un peu plus fragile
donc les parents sont plutôt sont plutôt
très inquiets et en même temps ils
souhaitent que leurs enfants reprennent
le chemin de l'école parce que c'est ce
qu'ils veulent les enfants c'est
reprendre l'école une vie un peu plus
normale en fait vous avez vous allez
rencontrer ou pas un représentant de
l'éducation nationale dans les prochains
jours c'est prévu ou pas de retour vous
nous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure voilà
donc
en fait on n'a aucun retour et surtout
non non en fait aujourd'hui on est le 19
août et en fait on n'a toujours aucun
contact avec le ministère l'éducation
nationale merci caravane du goût d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes co présidente de la fcpe
nationale